you
hi everyone it's Jerry I was just doing
a group of chess puzzles and came across
this one
and it turned out to be an endgame study
and I found it appropriate for this
playlist this cool chess puzzles
playlist certainly very clever
it's a in-game study or composition by a
pro cop unaware of the year it was
created and/or published if you have
those details feel free to inform me in
the comments and I'll be sure to they
update the description and a title to
this video but anyhow it's a white to
move in this one if you'd like to go
ahead and pause the video see if you can
find the solution to this one okay the
solution here is to first take on 83
there's only two moves to really
consider as black the best move is to
take on a three playing b3 there now
follows Bishop to e5 just preparing to
stop the pawn from advancing so black
has to take and now white is in fact
going to be pushing through and getting
the Queen with check black will promote
first but white again will get the Queen
with check and after a couple key checks
let's say Queen C four you can now push
through and it gets a little bit more
complicated but in the end white is of
course the better side here the winning
side they will be promoting soon enough
getting another queen so that said you
have to take on a3 instead of playing b3
and now the timing is super important
here black is now working with a passed
rook pawn which means when they promote
it will be with check so what to do here
playing this move Bishop e5 is no longer
working because again black will be
promoting with check and they're in a
position to stop cleaning
so you play the move King 2a8
how clever is that very sneaky move
black is needing to push the threat here
is Bishop a7 Bishop d4 stopping the pond
from promoting so you need to push right
away a to Bishop a7 still and now what
to do is black you have to promote yet
again and the big question here is what
to promote to exactly the typical
promotion to a queen this is now
stalemate and similarly promoting to a
rook that's stalemate and going to any
one of two minor pieces let's start off
first with a knight this is the
trickiest go figure promoting to Knight
this will result in a draw initially I
thought it would be a white win but
black is in time to hunt down the F pawn
like so and will be in a position to
control the g8 square pivoting on either
eise evan or h6 to do so if bishop here
to kind of box the knight out well when
this pawn pushes h6 is no longer
defended by the bishop so that will the
short story here is promoting to a
knight is a draw and one last promotion
promoting to a bishop here there's now
yet another cool move bishop d4 and you
have to capture the bishop and this is
yet again another instance of stalemate
so this was a very spur-of-the-moment
video here again like i said I was just
doing a group of puzzles and came across
this one it turned out to be a study and
a cool one at that
so hopefully you enjoyed it feel free to
leave any comments in the comment
section below to this video and as
always I hope you enjoyed it that's all
for now take care bye
you